παρόλο που είχα πρόβλημα αμέσως μετά ακολούθησαν τέσερα χειρουργεία στο ποδι που όλο ν αυτόν
ήταν πάρα πολύ δύσκολο δύο χρόνια δεν μπορούσα ούτε όχι για προπόνεισ ντοσυ ζηταραμε παρόλα
αυτά τά αυτόν τον χειρουργείο βοήθεσε μααρκετά τότε ι ατρός πουμε χειρούργησε και στηνοσιά ήθελα
λίγο να κλείσω τωτο κεφάλιον κυριάκοσιο άν άλλομα εσύψως μέσα σεέναν αγώ ναν α πρωτιμούσα
και στην κύπρον να έκλινα το το κομμάτι μου αυτό μέναν αγώνα δεν τα κατέφερα
ήρθε και το κόπιπεριορισμεί το έναντ άλλον οικογένεια περίμενα δεύτερο παιδίδεν ήταν ευκολον πότε έκλεισε
κάπως περιεργαια εμένα ήταν περιόδος που επεριπε να το κλείσω δεν ήθελα να το κλείσω
έτσι παρόλα αυτά σίγουράε με πάρα πολύ γεμάτος πάρα πολύ ικανοποιημένος με το εαυτόμου δεν
θα πω θα μπορούσα να έκανα και επεριστότια θα μπορούσαμε έκάνα και τίποτα θα παιδιά
να σου επιδε έκανε σανάφορα θέλεις να σχοληθούμε τον αφρετισμό θέλω να σχοληθούν και ίδια
σχουνούν τα δύο μου τα παιδάκαια ασχολούνται είναι στην ακαδημία μου επαθεί θέλω να έχουν
επαθού με το χρό όχι μόνο με τον κλασι τοκον αθηλισμόν ο γιώσ μου πάει
και ποδόσφορο πάεικαι πάσκεται λίγο θέλω να έχουν επαθεί με τον αφλητισμό και από γα
πέραννα ακολουθήσουν κάτι επαγγελματικά ένααυτό που τους τεριάζει εγώ θα μεδίπλα τους δεν θα πισω
κανένα αν δεν ήσουν αθλητή στο άλμα εσύψως αλλά ήθελες να είσ αθλητήσ σε πιο
άθμα θα θελες να τίσοκοίταξε δεν μπορού να αρχαντάστω τωεαυτό μου ή ίσως τερματοφύλακας στην
αέλναι ταξ λογικό να τε έχομε και πρβλημα αν ει νομίζω μόο το μεναφύλακαν έχοε
πρόλημα ολααλλά ς